>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
AND WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
IF YOU'RE AN AMERICAN, YOU
ASSUME THERE'S ONE KIND OF
DEMOCRACY, THE KIND YOU
GREW UP WITH.
THAT WOULD BE THE
DEMOCRACY WHERE CITIZENS
GOVERN THEMSELVES THROUGH
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES,
CHOSEN IN FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS BY SECRET
BALLOT.
IN THAT DEMOCRACY, YOU GET
TO ELECT ANYONE YOU WANT
BECAUSE IT IS YOUR
GOVERNMENT.
THE COUNTRY BELONGS TO
YOU, ITS CITIZENS.
THAT'S TRADITIONAL
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
IT EXISTS TO SERVE YOU.
THAT'S THE KNOW THE ONLY
KIND OF DEMOCRACY, THERE'S
ALSO THE SOVIET VERSION OF
DEMOCRACY, SAME WORD BUT
VERY DIFFERENT DEFINITION.
BOWL HAS CONVICTION TOOK
POWER BY PROMISING MORE
DEMOCRACY.
THE COUNTRY THAT CREATED
THE SOVIET UNION BECAME
THE MOST IMPRESSIVE POLICE
STATE IN HUMAN HISTORY.
YET IT WAS, YOU SHOULD
KNOW, A DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY CALLED
IT.
EAST GERMANY WAS A
DEMOCRACY, TOO, SO WAS
NORTH VIETNAM, AND
ETHIOPIA, AND ALBANIA.
DEMOCRACIES ALL.
IN HIS FIRST SPEECH AS
LEADER OF NORTH KOREA IN
1946, KIM I WILL SUNG
TALKED ABOUT DESTRUCTION
OF OPPOSITION TO HIS RULE,
KILLING OF POLITICAL
OPPONENTS AS DEMOCRATIC
REFORM.
ALMOST 80 YEARS LATER, KIM
JONG-UN CONTINUES TO RUN
NORTH KOREA AS A
DEMOCRACY, A SOVIET STYLE
DEMOCRACY.
SO AGAIN, THEY'RE USING A
VERY DIFFERENT DEFINITION
OF THE WORD.
IN THEIR VERSION OF
DEMOCRACY ALL DECISIONS
ARE MADE BY A SHADOWY
OLIGARCHY.
FRONT BY A STRONG MAN.
THE POINT ISN'T TO FIND
OUT WHAT THE POPULATION
THINKS OR WANTS, IT IS TO
LEND AURA OF LEGITIMACY TO
CRIMINALS ALREADY IN
CHARGE.
HERE IS JOSEPH STALIN
BRAGGING ABOUT RESULTS OF
THE 1937 SOVIET ELECTION
WHERE HIS PARTY WON 99.4%
SUPPORT.
89 MILLION VOTES TO
562,000 VOTES FOR THE
OTHER GUYS, WHOEVER THEY
WERE.
>> OUR ELECTIONS STALIN
WENT ON TO SAY ARE THE
ONLY FREE AND DEMOCRATIC
ELECTIONS IN THE WHOLE
WORLD.
AT THE MOMENT STALIN SPOKE
THOSE WORDS, HE WAS BUSY
MURDERING MORE THAN A
MILLION CITIZENS FOR
POLITICAL CRIMES IN WHAT
BECAME KNOWN AS THE GREAT
PURGE.
ACROSS THE OCEAN HERE IN
THE U.S. IT WAS CLEAR EVEN
AT THE TIME WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN THE SOVIET
UNION.
STALIN SHOW TRIALS WERE
PUBLIC AND OBVIOUSLY
TOTALITARIAN.
BUT THE AMERICAN LEFT
SUPPORTED STALIN ANYWAY,
THAT INCLUDES SOME OF OUR
COUNTRY'S MOST FAMOUS
INTELLECTUALS AND
CELEBRITIES AND
JOURNALISTS.
"NEW YORK TIMES" WAS ALL
IN.
THIS TURNED OUT TO BE THE
VERSION OF DEMOCRACY THEY
SUPPORTED, STALIN'S
VERSION.
WHY ARE WE TELLING YOU ALL
OF THIS?
BECAUSE YOU'RE HEARING A
LOT ABOUT DEMOCRACY
LATELY.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHICH VERSION
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
JOE BIDEN GAVE A SPEECH
ABOUT DEMOCRACY LAST
NIGHT.
HERE'S PART OF WHAT HE
SAID.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE
AT STAKE, DEMOCRACY
ITSELF.
I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE WHO
SEES IT.
WE MUST VOTE KNOWING
WHAT'S AT STAKE, NOT JUST
THE POLICY OF THE MOMENT,
BUT INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE
HELD US TOGETHER AS WE
SOUGHT A MORE PERFECT
UNION ARE ALSO AT STAKE.
WE MUST VOTE KNOWING WHO
WE ARE THEN, WHAT WE'RE AT
RISK OF BECOMING.
THIS IS THE STRUGGLE WE'RE
NOW IN, A STRUGGLE FOR
DEMOCRACY.
A STRUGGLE FOR DECENCY AND
DIGNITY, A STRUGGLE FOR
PROSPERITY AND PROGRESS.
A STRUGGLE FOR THE VERY
SOUL OF AMERICA ITSELF.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, DEMOCRACY
IS ON THE BALLOT FOR ALL
OF US.
>> DEMOCRACY IS ON THE
BALLOT, SAYS JOE BIDEN.
NO, JOE BIDEN, NAMES OF
CANDIDATES ARE ON THE
BALLOT.
DEMOCRACY IS NOT ON THE
BALLOT BECAUSE DEMOCRACY
ISN'T DETERMINED BY THE
OUTCOME OF AN ELECTION.
DEMOCRACY IS THE ELECTION
ITSELF.
DEMOCRACY IS THE PROCESS
BY WHICH CITIZENS CHOOSE
HOW THEY WILL BE GOVERNED
ACCORDING TO THEIR OWN
DESIRES.
THAT'S THEIR CHOICE.
IT'S NOT YOURS.
BUT JOE BIDEN IS TELLING
YOU THE OPPOSITE AND YOU
SHOULD KNOW THAT.
HE IS TELLING YOU UNLESS
YOU ARRIVE AT A VERY
SPECIFIC OUTCOME, THE VERY
OUTCOME HE COMMANDS YOU TO
ARRIVE AT, THE SYSTEM
ITSELF IS ILLEGITIMATE.
WE CONTROL THE SYSTEM, WE
HAVE A MORE WILL A RIGHT
TO CONTROL THE SYSTEM.
THEREFORE, IF WE LOSE
CONTROL OF THE SYSTEM, THE
SYSTEM ITSELF CAN NO
LONGER EXIST.
THIS IS A DRAMATIC
MISREADING OF WHAT
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY IS.
IN AMERICAN DEMOCRACY,
PEOPLE THAT CONTROL THE
SYSTEM ONLY HAVE A RIGHT
TO CONTROL THE SYSTEM TO
THE EXTENT THE PUBLIC
GRANTS THEM THAT RIGHT
THROUGH VOTING.
WHAT BIDEN IS DESCRIBING
IS THE SOVIET VERSION OF
DEMOCRACY, WHERE ELECTIONS
EXIST TO RATIFY THE STATUS
QUO, TO BOLSTER THE CABAL
ALREADY IN POWER.
THAT'S EFFECTIVELY WHAT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
SAYING OUT LOUD NOW.
HERE IS BARACK OBAMA.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT
DEMOCRACY MIGHT NOT SEEM
LIKE A TOP PRIORITY RIGHT
NOW, BUT WE HAVE SEEN
THROUGHOUT HISTORY AND WE
SEE RIGHT NOW AROUND THE
WORLD WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU GIVE UP ON DEMOCRACY.
YOU CAN SEE IT IN
COUNTRIES WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT TELLS YOU WHAT
BOOKS YOU CAN AND CANNOT
READ, COUNTRIES WHERE IF
YOU DISSENT, YOU ARE PUT
IN JAIL, COUNTRIES WHERE
REPORTERS ARE SILENCED.
>> OH, HE IS SLICK.
BUT IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE
HE REALLY MEANS THAT.
QUOTE, I UNDERSTAND THAT
DEMOCRACY MIGHT NOT SEEM
LIKE A TOP PRIORITY NOW,
SAID BARACK OBAMA.
REALLY?
THE OPPOSITE IS SO
OBVIOUSLY TRUE.
DEMOCRACY IS VERY MUCH A
TOP PRIORITY FOR SO MANY
AMERICANS THIS NOVEMBER.
AND THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
SEEING RECORD TURNOUT IN
MIDTERM ELECTIONS BECAUSE
VOTERS ARE USING THE ONLY
POWER THEY HAVE, THEIR
BALLOTS, IN OUR DEMOCRACY
TO PUNISH THEIR RECKLESS,
INCOMPETENT LEADERS AND
REPLACE THEM WITH SOMEBODY
ELSE.
SO WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
UNMISTAKABLY IS DEMOCRACY
IN ACTION.
THAT WOULD BE VERY OBVIOUS
TO ANYONE THAT BELIEVES
THAT DEMOCRACY MEANS
REPRESENTATION.
BUT TO THOSE THAT BELIEVE
THAT DEMOCRACY MEANS
SUPPORTING THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY NO MATTER WHAT IT
DOES, TO THOSE PEOPLE,
THIS MOMENT HAS A VERY
DIFFERENT FEEL.
THIS MOMENT FEELS LIKE AN
EMERGENCY.
A REJECTION OF JOE BIDEN'S
PARTY FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE IS THE END OF
THE SYSTEM ITSELF, AND
THEY CLEARLY BELIEVE THAT,
THEY MEAN IT.
THAT'S WHY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SPENT THE
LAST TWO YEARS DESTROYING
THE TWO PREREQUISITES FOR
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY, THOSE
WOULD BE FREE SPEECH AND
THE RULE OF LAW.
THAT'S WHY THEY SILENCED
DISOBEDIENT REPORTERS, PUT
THEIR POLITICAL OPPONENTS
IN JAIL.
IT IS WHY FBI AGENTS WITH
AUTOMATIC RIFLES DRAGGED
CHRISTIANS FROM THEIR
HOMES FOR THE CRIME OF
PRAYING AT AN ABORTION
CLINIC.
NONVIOLENT PROTESTERS
REMAIN IN JAIL FOR DARING
TO WALK INTO WHAT USED TO
BE CALLED THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE BECAUSE AS FAR AS
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
CONCERNED, THAT HOUSE NO
LONGER BELONGS TO THE
PEOPLE, IT BELONGS TO THE
PARTY, ALONG WITH THE
ENTIRE U.S. GOVERNMENT AND
THE NATION ITSELF.
THAT'S HOW THEY THINK.
IF YOU REALLY BELIEVE THAT
YOU HAD A MORAL RIGHT TO
GOVERN FOREVER, AND THEY
REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT,
YOU WOULD SEE ELECTIONS
VERY DIFFERENTLY.
YOU WOULDN'T VIEW THE LOSS
OF A MIDTERM CYCLE AS THE
USUAL HEALTHY REBALANCING
OF AMERICAN POLITICS, TOO
FAR ONE DIRECTION, SWING
BACK TOWARD THE OTHER
SIDE, THE KIND OF THING
THAT HAPPENED COUNTLESS
TIMES IN OUR, YES,
DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S WHAT'S SUPPOSED TO
HAPPEN.
BUT YOU WOULDN'T SEE THAT.
YOU WOULDN'T SEE THE LOSS
OF YOUR OWN POLITICAL
POWER AS LOSS OF
EVERYTHING, AS TOTAL
DESTRUCTION OF THE SYSTEM
ITSELF, THE BEGINNING OF
THE DARK AGES.
IF YOU BELIEVE THAT, YOU
MIGHT BE HYSTERICAL, AND
THEY ARE.
WATCH.
>> DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE
IN THIS ELECTION, NEVADA.
>> MADE IT CLEAR THAT
DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE THIS
NOVEMBER.
>> DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE
THIS NOVEMBER.
>> DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE.
>> OUR DEMOCRACY IS AT
STAKE.
>> THE FUTURE OF OUR
DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE.
>> WE ALL KNOW DEMOCRACY
IS AT STAKE.
>> THIS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELECTION COMING
UP, DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE.
>> NOTHING LESS THAN THE
FUTURE OF DEMOCRACY IS AT
STAKE.
>>.
>> Tucker: IT IS
NONSENSICAL TO MOST
AMERICANS.
ISN'T THIS DEMOCRACY?
DISSATISFIED WITH ONE
THING, WE ARE CHOOSING
ANOTHER?
ISN'T THAT THE MOST BASIC
RIGHT?
NO.
NOT ACCORDING TO THE
PEOPLE YOU JUST SAW.
AND KEEP IN MIND, THOSE
WEREN'T JUST TALKING
POINTS YOU HEARD, THE
PEOPLE MOUTHING THOSE
WORDS BELIEVE THEM
SINCERELY, EVERY ONE OF
THEM, AND THEY'RE
EMOTIONAL ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE IF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY GOES, SO DO THEY.
THE PARTY IS THE ONLY
POWER THEY HAVE.
ONCE THAT PARTY HAS BEEN
REJECTED, THEY'LL BE
NOTHING BUT WHAT THEY
ALREADY ARE, SAD MIDDLE
AGED IMMEDIATE OOH
OBJECTING KRIT OHS WITH
NOTHING INTERESTING TO
SAY.
EVERYTHING IS ON THE LINE
FOR THEM.
THEY CAN'T LOSE.
AND BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
LOSE THEY'RE GETTING
EXPLICIT ABOUT WHAT IF.
HERE'S RON KLAIN, JOE
BIDEN'S ALL POWERFUL CHIEF
OF STAFF ISSUING EXPLICIT
THREAT TO ANYONE THINKING
OF VOTING THE WRONG WAY
NEXT TUESDAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT DECIDED A
FEW DAYS AGO IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO ISSUE ONE
FINAL WARNING ON THIS
ISSUE, TO MAKE VERY CLEAR
TO LEAVE NO DOUBT THAT WE
HAVE PEOPLE OUT THERE
STILL PEDALLING THE BIG
LIE, PEOPLE NOW RAISING
THE ELECTION OF ELECTION
DENIAL IN THIS ELECTION.
>> Tucker: ONE FINAL
WARNING?
ONE FINAL WARNING, REALLY?
WHO DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
TALKING TO, RON KLAIN,
ILLITERATE VILLAGERS?
WE ARE AMERICANS.
WE ARE FREE PEOPLE.
YOU DON'T GET TO WARN US
OF ANYTHING, MUCH LESS FOR
THE LAST TIME.
THIS IS YOUR FINAL
WARNING.
YEAH.
DON'T THINK SO.
YOU DON'T GET TO SAY THAT,
RON KLAIN.
YOU DON'T GET TO SAY
ANYTHING LIKE THAT EVER
BECAUSE THIS IS A
DEMOCRACY.
AN AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
NOT A SOVIET DEMOCRACY.
IN OUR SYSTEM YOU DON'T
GET TO ISSUE ORDERS TO THE
REST OF US ON THE EVE OF
AN ELECTION.
NO.
YOU BEG FOR OUR CONSENT
BECAUSE OUR CONSENT IS THE
ONLY LEGITIMACY YOU HAVE.
THIS IS OUR GOVERNMENT, IT
IS NOT YOURS